a Brit and an American swap countries to
try each other's KFC this is food Wars
[Music]
we're gonna start with some things you
can get in both the US and the UK to see
if there are some subtle differences in
taste or anything else the first thing
for me to try the main event the Fried
Chicken so there's just original recipe
chicken I've got what looks to be a
thigh piece visually I think it probably
looks slightly more appealing than
British fried chicken from KFC tends to
look the breading is like all over the
place there's no bare patches here I
always struggle to like identify where
the bones are in pieces of KFC I just
wanted to bite straight into a bone
um
okay yeah this is good compared to the
UK I think I definitely am getting more
flavor I think a fair amount of that is
coming from the breading it's actual
seasoning and flavor
it looks like a thick juicy piece of
chicken I don't want to go back to
eating regular British KFC after this
right this six piece bucket this looks
like it has more skin than what we got
in the restaurant I will say celebrity
this looks like it has a Better Batter
to it
that is so Bland so I can taste the
flavors and I was like strong and I'm
assuming that's the chemicals we put in
our food to make it taste like yes the
next thing we wanted to compare was
popcorn chicken which I think in the UK
is a pretty iconic menu item although
weirdly enough they've actually cut it
from the menu in the US right now the
exception being that they will still add
it to famous bowls but we'll get to that
later so I guess for the time being I
will try a U.S chicken nuggets and see
how that compares I mean like this just
kind of looks like popcorn chicken
I'm definitely a bit more dry on the
palette again I don't see why they've
got rid of popcorn chicken in lieu of
these because popcorn chicken is
effectively the same thing there's like
a shot
whoa how's him well I don't taste
anything so far I would say that KFC
chicken both on the bone and popcorn in
the U.S the flavor is more pronounced
and has more of like a Savory flavor to
it this flavor has training wheels
it'll get there someday
firstly there are some twists on the
classic Fried Chicken which we can't
usually find the first variety we have
here is the spicy fried chicken I mean
like visually this looks fairly similar
to just the sort of standard original
recipe although I will say the uh the
breading looks pretty good you get a lot
of these little like flakes of breading
which really tend to get crisp and stay
crisp
I don't know there's enough to call it
spicy because I'm not like a guy who has
a super high spice tolerance and for me
that's like warm but not much more than
that it's very pleasant and I do think
it's crispier than the original recipe
very juicy flavorful I think this is
really good I think I would be tempted
to buy this over just classic original
recipe and it's not just spicy chicken
that's available in the US you can also
get another type called extra crispy as
the name suggests it's the regular Fried
Chicken but made extra crispy I think
extra crispy should be the KFC chicken
then the original should be like Diet
for some reason the branch that we went
to today didn't have it in the form of
regular original recipe chicken but they
did have it in the form of a chicken
little I'm just gonna like break off the
end bit that was Untouched by the Mayo
to see if it is actually crispy or not
I don't think this is extra crispy even
though they told us it was maybe there
are the crispinator was broken today or
something
KFC us is very good at cooking chicken
on the bone but that's good when it
comes to cooking chicken off the bone
because this is a little bit dry a
little bit chewy Moving On The Snack
Wrap This one is the Flaming hat
oh wow this is awesome into it okay okay
yeah that's I like this this is really
good Kansas barbecue okay
this barbecue sauce is pretty good I
mean this is definitely a sweeter sauce
which I think is indicative of Kansas
City Barbecue anyway you know not bad
sweet chili bites
too sweet not that spicy now we're onto
an item which I've been watching from
across the pond with a mixture of horror
and Fascination it's the KFC famous bowl
instead of me trying to explain it I
feel like we should just get Joe in here
Joe do you want to come and explain the
famous bowl to me a little bit
everything is on the menu just in Bull
form
for anyone who just pretty much given up
on life and still doesn't care as long
as they get in their stomach thanks Joe
you're welcome it's looking more like an
Infamous Bowl right now I'm gonna
it's not horrible there's just a lot
going on there's a lot of flavors
fighting with each other right now vying
for Supremacy the main thing I get I
think is the corn actually I would have
assumed that the mash and the chicken
would have been kind of the stars of the
show but if anything it's everything
else in there that you can actually
taste more
to me it feels a little bit like you're
eating baby food for adults I was gonna
say I'm more excited to try the next
Bowl but I don't know if excited is the
word maybe less anxious to try the next
Bowl this is the KFC nut and cheese Bowl
but the kind of color on that is uh some
course for concern
so I think this actually
Works in harmony with the chicken much
better than the famous bowl does if I
had to get a bowl I think I would be
leaning more towards the mac and cheese
ball than the famous bowl next up is the
KFC pot pie it's funny to see this on
the menu at a KFC in the US because I
feel like meat pies are generally
associated with Britain more we love a
meat pie in the UK steak pie chicken pie
Greg's pucker pies all that good stuff
so with like a meat pie in the UK what
you'll often get is the pastry on the
bottom as well so it's like a
self-contained pie whereas I think with
a pot pie you just have a layer of
pastry on top and then filling
underneath and there's no bottom layer
of crust but let's find out
they haven't skimped on the carrot I
taste a lot of the carrot flavor in the
UK for example with a meat pie you tend
to get like a gravy that will kind of
run out when you cut into it but this is
like staying on the spoon it's not like
running off the spoon it's not great but
it's not bad either it's like the sauce
needs a little bit more seasoning I
think it's a little bit Bland a bit more
salt and pepper would not go I missed
that I think with a few minor
adjustments they can make this really
good and I do think Brits would go for
this so this is super weird look at that
there's a hash brown that was that what
does that do with like Tower not much
hmm I like everything that this is made
of together I don't think it works
supposed to get this I'd ask them to
separate it across three containers and
let's see what is it the hash brown then
the chicken finish it off with a slice
of cheese there you go this would be
close to like what our extra crispy is
this is supposed to be a spicy one it's
going to zing me with spice
[Music]
not bad it's not that I dislike anything
I've had so far
is that it's all 60 to 70 percent as far
as flavor and intensity that I'm used to
in the United States you can also get
yourself a Zinger stacker and a Zinger
Tower Burger yo it is a thick one wow
I'm not gonna bite into this but man
that's a lot this would be right at home
on the U.S menu this would be like yes
of course it's like the double Zinger
and everyone's like yeah of course it's
double
okay vegan burger
kind of looks like chicken
the Mayo pretty much missed it right see
how they all came so I got to kind of
like activate the Mayo
twist your vegan sandwich before you eat
it it's even ask what the Mayo's made of
I mean we rip it apart it's like one of
those big erasers
I mean I wouldn't just want to eat this
in general but as far as a fake meat
it's pretty close and I don't know why
if you were vegan you'd be like finally
a chicken sandwich at KFC no you can eat
this there's no chicken meat and say
yeah but you're still killing them by
the millions so there is a category in
the menu of Twisters rice boxes and
salads they had no rice boxes or salads
they did however have the twisters
but this is called a twister not a wrap
what's Twisted about it let's not twist
it looks like they took a chicken breast
and cut it in half and this was like one
long tender
it's also smaller I bet they like wanted
to like appeal to more like male
demographic so don't get arrested
twister I'm a big man I didn't really
want to ramble I swear he has Twisted
raps are for the ladies the dudes have
twisters I don't think that they think
that's KFC shame on you let's talk about
some exclusive sides that you can't find
in the UK firstly if the mac and cheese
bowl is too much mac and cheese for you
you can just get a little cup as a side
you can also get a side of corn you guys
just produce so much of it you can't get
rid of it fast enough uh I'm not trying
corn and like uh here in uh the UK you
guys have corn on the cob obviously ours
is corn off the cob but this would be
easier for driving or like eating on the
go right have you ever seen someone
walking down the streets there's two in
a and a carb on a stick then a stick
you've never seen that keep your eyes
filled I would like to get that Trend
going and of course apparently it
wouldn't be a U.S fast food menu without
biscuits this is an American biscuit it
looks a lot like a British Scott at
least on the outside however generally I
think it's a bit more like bready and
maybe slightly drier than a scone
to check
it's confusing because with a British
gun they're generally like sweetened
with sugar because they're eaten with
things like jam and cream and it's more
of an afternoon tea slash dessert type
thing whereas these ones are supposed to
be eaten with a Savory meal but actually
smell kind of sweet I think of the
biscuits I've tried from fast food menus
in the US so far this is probably my
favorite one but it's somewhere between
like a British scone and a bread roll
baked beans
well yeah these are way more tomatoey
tomato excuse me the tomato sauce and
it's in it's like similar to like
whatever SpaghettiOs come in I will
never be in the mood for that southern
rice
what the hell I don't know what they
think southern is I'm surprised at how
different it is you think an
International Food chamber wanted to be
same everywhere but applying to the UK
tastes I assume KFC in the US has a
bunch of source options that we can't
get in the UK which means it's time for
sauce top for an exchange the theme
seems to be that they have a lot of
Honey on the menu when it comes to their
sources at KFC in the US the sauce is on
offer here are hot sauce honey sauce a
honey barbecue sauce KFC sauce and yet
more honey a honey mustard I usually
like a honey mustard but I do think you
have to get the balance of honey and
mustard right
yeah that's not bad that's a pretty well
balanced honey mustard I think I'm
intrigued by KFC sauce
I quite like it I really can't put my
finger on exactly what's in it right now
next up we've got the honey barbecue
oh extremely sweet both on the honey
side and even on the kind of barbecue
side let's have a look at the honey
sauce it's fine it does taste pretty
much just like honey and then finally
they have a hot sauce yeah that's pretty
comparable to like a Frank's Red Hot
barbecue
okay Kentucky Smoke Barbecue actually
this is on point sticky sweet chili
sauce why is it sticky
yeah oh that's good all right garlic
buttermilk Mayo I like all three of
those things separately
yeah it's pretty good now let's look at
some exclusive drinks served in these
delightful Diablo branded cups you guys
love a advertisement tie-in day so I
believe this one is Starry Joe's beloved
Sierra Mist unfortunately cold recently
and replaced by Starry let's give it a
try
it's more what I'm used to I guess from
like a UK version of a lemonade style
drink and of course we have a U.S style
lemonade
it's pretty good again to me it's
slightly weird what Americans consider
lemonade considering coming from the UK
lemonade is basically Sprite it's like a
clear carbonated lemony beverage it's
pretty good it's probably like slightly
more refreshing and hydrating than a
Sprite is in the UK there are a couple
of other exclusive drinks which we can
normally get but unfortunately our local
branch did not have devastatingly
because I really wanted to try the
Mountain Dew sweet lightning and regular
American Mountain Dew when we ordered
the bottles of drinks didn't we think it
was just going to be like a a personal
one I don't know the Tango orange seven
up free Pepsi Next Cherry crushums UK of
course has exclusive crushing drinks and
in front of me I said give me one of
each and they did milky bar
there's more we're still charging the
same but it's just says you get less in
there so okay less calories by default
because it's all there
I might be the last person to point this
out but like they took the candy bar and
they crushed it and that's why it's
Crush thems okay Oreo one I mean come on
that's really good I would definitely
get this dessert exclusive desserts get
a white chocolate chip cookie you could
also get a pineapple stick but they
didn't have any at the location we went
to also I don't know what a pineapple
stick is
was that desserts
I think if I could pick one item from
this menu to take back with me to the UK
and put on our menu over there I think
it would probably be the spicy chicken I
just like how it was slightly more
crispy than the regular chicken and just
added a bit more flavor the level of
heat was really good yeah I think that
would come back with me if I could
remove one thing from the US and all
other menus from KFC I think it would be
the famous bowl I'm sorry guys I don't
want to start some kind of Revolutionary
War again but I just feel like it's not
very good because those ingredients
don't really go together texturally it's
a bit of a nightmare and honestly
there's just way better things you can
do with the stuff on the menu I was
really impressed with the the Flamin Hot
wrap I made a dog then a little bit
earlier because it was smaller but that
spicy sauce you guys have is actually
pretty good honorable mention the vegan
burger obvious I'm not vegan but I guess
I was surprised by how kind of decent it
was it's not my favorite but I mean
points for it being edible
way to go uh I will do everyone a favor
and I will say I'm not cutting a menu
item let's get that potato off of your
sandwiches they just don't work together
period